in the lobby of Ramsey solutions page
and ampere are here hey welcome welcome
we're so excited to be here more honored
to have you where are you from we hailed
from Durham North Carolina
very cool best place on the planet I
think that's true it is it is awesome
yeah I like Durham yeah Raleigh the
Raleigh area both of them we come over
there all the time
sweet so welcome man good to have you
guys so you aren't here to do a
debt-free scream finally I love finally
here to do a debt-free scream how much
have you paid off paid off sixty eight
thousand dollars in roughly two and a
half years very good and your range of
income during that time when we first
started it was around $26,000 and when
we finished it was around ninety one
thousand I'm done here our Sun our
background very cool how old is your son
19 months 19 months but he's a perfect
age to scream I've got a 14 month old
and a 1 year old grand daughters and
they both sound like pterodactyls we
want to scream like nobody's in the race
you know they're not Ramsay's but they
got the Ramsey vocal cords so anyway hey
so what started you guys on this track
two and a half years ago I would say
it's all God I was graduated college
from Appalachian State University in
2010 and then moved to Korea was very
unhappy with my life and I was like
using credit cards and there's a point
when I was in Korea and I was just
frustrated with the fact that I was
using credit cards and just broke all
the time and so I was just praying and
God was like it's time do you trust me
or not and I said alright I trust you so
I cut off my credit cards and I was
broke and God provided for me the whole
time and I got back to America from
Korea and amber and I started dating on
that during that time yeah and Paige
said amber you got to read this book I
had debt on my own so that was in 2011
and I was really into this guy so I was
like sure I'll read this book I got
finished
day and I was totally on board and we
out yeah and we got married maybe about
two years later I have no idea
two years later a while back we got
married not too long ago but that's our
fun yeah so we didn't like combine our
finances or anything obviously until we
got married but I was really encouraging
amber to pay off her debt and she had a
job where she was able to do that and I
had a job where I was able to do that
too
but so what a lot of debt was the 68000
all school loans pretty much what some
credit card yeah and some credit cards
and I had a computer payment which is
really silly you go the greatest thing
about it was that amber went to school
college for free and I braced basically
when the college for free and so we
somehow I ended up with sixty eight
thousand dollars in debt going to
college for free which credit card yeah
yeah this was like evenly split debt or
more Amber's or more than me yeah more
college yeah more college day okay you
need clean up the credit cards a from
Korea but after that still had the
college debt and so about half and a
half give or take and yeah and he a
little bit more and then here we go so
you get you get married and you both
read the book because you're dating
boyfriend talked you into it yeah and
then we're here we go off on this
adventure Valencia influential boyfriend
she they have a choice if she was gonna
be dating me she had to be financially
responsible so that's just if you could
if you could pull it off do it yeah
during the time we lived in Austin and I
got a second job working Outback
Steakhouse I had my first job I wasn't
making any money like 26,000 like I said
and it was crazy because I was like I'm
in sales I'm doing this job and I'm not
making any Commission and it's just
really awful so I was working like 80
hours a week and that out back and I was
like really tired but I was like Mabel
to make way more money to hang out with
him out back and eat the free bread
bloomin onion gave her free bread don't
tell don't tell
you buddy she did not pay for it the
yeah yeah yeah they are right in the
front on you I caught them out back I
got on they're right here
I'll hold them for you Oh way to go you
guys well very fun very fun so what do
you tell people when they find out you
paid off sixty eight thousand dollars
and they say how did you do that what
are you telling the key to getting out
of that is well I would say get used to
say no we if your friends ask you to
basically leave the house just say no
yeah I think we said no so many times
that people stop asking us to hang out
no but we tried to get our friends to
play act your wage with us which was one
of the more challenging we bought at
your wage because we're like yo we're in
this thing let's see if this game is fun
we play with Amber's little brother and
sister and we tried to get other people
on board yeah I got some um we did get a
couple friends on budgets okay remember
in Dallas yeah we were pretty hardcore
about it and I know that you're probably
gonna ask us what the hardest thing was
about it and that was probably the
hardest thing because all the knows well
not so much the nose but laying in
social being so passionate about wanting
to pay off debt and talking other people
about it and they're just not being on
board or not being as passionate about
it as we were and we're like why don't
you understand this thing that we're
doing it's awesome and it is applicable
to everybody on the planet it's funny
how when you doing something like that
I'm the same way I feel like if they're
not doing it they're stupid yeah yeah
yeah that's how it feels I know that's
that's very well maybe there's an
element of truth to that they're not
necessarily stupid but they have a
different view of money that's probably
incorrect when they're looking at money
and say you cleaned that up more money
than they make that's not responsible
I've heard you say before Dave that you
can't change people mm-hmm
so that is a hard part of this process
as you're winning you're getting
traction you can see the light how
you're gonna be out I'm gonna be out
right over there
you know and you can't talk somebody
else into it as much as you love the
people yeah doesn't
yes that that is a hard part I hadn't
heard that one in a while but that's a
really good one very cool well
congratulations you guys I'm very proud
of you preciate it be a cop signed copy
of Chris Hogan's new book looking at one
that's awesome I also wanted to say
before we do a screen that I am when we
got out of debt I posted my story on
Reddit and we made the front page and
yeah it was pretty awesome I got a lot
of publicity because of that just like
the story we had started a business in
the same time while we were getting out
of debt and we sold the business and we
just did a lot of like extra stuff
obviously to get momentum and pay off
the debt a lot a lot faster so
congratulations yeah so proud of you
guys your hero's way to go okay so your
19 month olds name is what Gideon Gideon
Gideon Gideon to me a little man
so has big Gideon practice in his debt
free scream yeah all right page amber
and Gideon Durham North Carolina $68,000
paid off in two and a half years 26 to
91 count it down let's hear a debt free
scream 3
you guys we scared the baby that's what
I mean that's awesome hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show you can do
this you know that really is a message
whether you've got two hundred seventy
thousand dollars in student loan debt or
27 thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
the company